really nice to meet you nice to meet you
you must have inspired me I watch your
Dean shop and mashallah the things you
actually say educate my absolute
spreading the knowledge I'm also trying
to do what you are also and your mission
is that's all I would just like to
really I'm really inspired to actually
sees today
first time really lots of YouTube
channels out there and also in
particular the mashallah Deen show how
long does that be in broadcasting for
how long have you been producing that
and presenting on it no we started the
the Deen show back in 2006 2006 ever
since then we've been putting out shows
weekly and people can still continue to
tune in to the Deen show calm and every
week we have a new exciting episode
trying to clear many of the
misconceptions deliver the purpose of
life to the people and interview people
from all walks of life that have chosen
this way of life after really putting it
to the test they tried everything else
but they didn't find that peace
contentment happiness until they found
Islam and we try to highlight those
things
[Music]
[Music]
I get excited to do all of them I mean
when anytime I get a special person that
comes in I looked from those stories
that it helps me to also appreciate what
we have because many times we are born
into a family of Muslims while these
while many people they have to struggle
they had to really go through a lot a
lot of investigation a lot of hardship
and now they really appreciate the Deen
where we become more relaxed adacia
right we end up getting its Lomb just
put on the plane we think it's something
inherited know everyone has to make that
conscious decision to submit their will
to the crater to follow Islam and these
people have done that so every time I go
ahead and I see wow look at all these
struggles they went through and many of
us we don't appreciate that entertaining
one of the best women that ever walked
the earth and this is for the youth out
there many are taking the zayn malik's
as role models and many of the celebrity
pop stars but those are not our role
models you know and then they end up end
up following and attaching the hearts to
them and they end up you know taking the
wrong examples and we try to highlight
these you don't want to take them
examples right this young man he
invested a time he invested an effort
and now he's really appreciating this
and you can see the the life in him and
this is what really it just it motivates
me to keep going and and to share this
so other people can benefit from those
stories and really appreciate what we
have and not lose it because a man or
when we could take a few steps and lose
their soul one is the reminder of the
the reality of this life that is it's
short it can end at any time and that we
also we have to be in a constant state
of reconnecting with Allah every day and
and not to you know people go to the gym
constantly because if you don't use it
you lose it
so same thing with the Dean everything
is there along the Creator gives us the
tools for life how to get through many
of the struggles how to get through the
challenges what we need to be successful
what real success is so we end up taking
all of the other things that are out
there and we free abandon the Quran we
abandon our Deen and we think the
solutions and and everything is out and
we get it we're gonna get it from
somewhere else but we have it the
treasure is there we just have to go
ahead and appreciate it and learn it
many of times people for instance we
talked about how when people are not
empowered by the Deen and they become
apologetically Muslim and then that's
how you end up losing yourself and you
want to please everyone
you become a sycophant and you want to
end up pleasing everyone else other than
your Creator but the beautiful thing
about Dawa what the beautifu
think about when when you're involved in
sharing because I often say if you share
you care it is empowering you the more I
have interviewed people who come from
different walks of life let's say the
more they investigated the religion of
their parents the more they were
unconvinced of it but what led many of
these these scholars of other religions
and then they come into Islam the more
they investigate Islam the more they
empowered by it and the more they're
convinced of it but many Muslims they're
not convinced of it's not because they
don't study it they don't many have not
consciously submitted to Allah to their
creator and now when you when you spend
more time learning your Deen the more
you appreciate it the more you're gonna
naturally you're gonna you you're gonna
have no doubts about it and this is what
one of the beautiful things with the
Dawa is that this is forcing you to
learn because you don't no one wants to
be ignorant you want to be able to
answer these questions so now it's
empowering you and then naturally now
you're fulfilling an obligation which is
to go ahead and share to make the
communities we live in a better place
and this is this is our mission in life
that many of us were not we're not
seizing the opportunity and once asked
once were gone it's too late so we have
the opportunity now we have to take
advantage of that what's that mean there
you go also learn the Quran and teach it
yeah it's the straight path yes it opens
the he respecting your parents in the
car odd have you read it respecting your
parents GPS Jinnah we got the GPS
there's so many trappings of Shaitaan
there's so many things look it doesn't
mean that we neglect this world but many
have let this dunya penetrate the heart
so when you have it in your hand not in
your heart when it's time to let it go
you let it go so just trying to day by
day fulfill the obligations that are
loving created the most merciful has
told us to do and just keep moving
forward and just not to get too caught
up I mean do our part
to go ahead and establish put plant
seeds of goodness and do our part that
we have you know often reminds me of the
Iowa Lhasa inulin Sun and a few close in
Edina I manawa me know Sally Hardy went
about sober sober sober that Allah is
telling us mankind is in loss right by
time a lot of swine this is our time is
so valuable but we're we're just we're
just donating it giving it away to some
of the most ridiculous things out there
and except those who believe believe in
the pure monotheism believe in their
Creator the one who created them and
then they they invite the truth and
their pace and patience so I'm just
trying to adhere the best I can we all
make mistakes we all as the Prophet SAW
some said you know all of the sons of
mad Adam are sinners but the best of
those who come back to Allah constantly
so I'm trying to just do that that just
to be consistent just to be conscious of
Allah at all times we all make mistakes
for all humans but not to forget this
and get caught up into all the different
things that are out there that the
trappings of the shayateen shaitana
thank you the prophets go ahead who
Jesus peace be upon him in the car at
the last and final messenger set to
mankind the Prophet Muhammad what else
be thou eating the poor in the Quran and
this is what the good manners here is
bullying good manners bully it's
disrespecting your parents good manners
just give an invitation for every not
yet Muslim and I often say not yet
Muslim because everyone has the
potential to submit to their to creator
and many of the not yet Muslims they
have so many misconceptions about Islam
there's a beautiful at this Muslim
Heritage Center when you come in is
called the house of wisdom and you see
all from someone who's drinking coffee
someone who's visiting a hospital the
first Muslim universities from from a
Muslim woman I mean that just dispels
that the women are subjugated kept
ignorant
first Muslim made the university
the coffee the inventions hospitals all
of these wonderful things it's like gems
of wisdom that are there and just seeing
that how its portrayed to anybody who
come through here
I love the the exhibition that's the
first thing is you want to be the best
you know requires hard work and
dedication I'm going to say hard work
you see dedication hard work hard work
[Applause]
in the crowd chapter 2 verse 172 let's
see who can recite it mashallah oh you
who believe eat of the good things look
of the good things if you believe you
know Allah and be grateful thank you so
much see if you don't come visit a
mosque you don't know what the Muslims
all about you come in you got all of
these look look cooperate with one
another in goodness so they bring good
to the humanity and then you have all of
these different beautiful events cooking
events homeless winter food packs the
gardening club invents set up team
homeless winter and food packs and the
list goes on
clean up street project look at that
clean up street project Food Bank works
help needy project youth mentoring and
alistel's I'm going to name some of the
good things the tiny box we call it real
food because if you eat real food you'll
be really healthy you'll be really if
you eat fake food you're gonna be really
sick you're gonna be released sick okay
when I name a food and if it's real food
you're gonna say ding ding ding ding
ding if it's fake food you're gonna say
our our our fake food fake food
you guys ready - let's do it disaster
Appeals health awareness sessions
marriage education cleaning out
loneliness project adult games health
checks I mean the list goes on this is
what Muslims are about they are
worshiping their creator and a part of
worshiping is doing everything the
crater loves and that's being a benefit
to not just yourself but to humanity at
large visitor mosque here in the UK
manchester banana they got it
snicker bar date
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding
real food coca-cola
hey food you guys got it chicken
pop-tarts what can I say now the best
students easy to understand so we
covered a lot guys keep up the great
work we learned a lot hard work
dedication keep on keep moving forward
don't stop and hope to see you guys you
guys can see me all the time and what
the Dean show where we're at the
bookstore hit that moisturize this book
stood out here productive Muslim and I
recommend this book and I want to
encourage people because this is the
only brother that I've seen I'm really
into audiobooks now cuz I'm when you're
driving you can't read and drive so he's
one of the only brothers that I've seen
because there's a lot of anti Islam
books out there so we really need to
catch up and start doing these
audiobooks that's the new things would
author just reads the book and this
brother actually has that one of the few
that I've seen so I really recommend
this and others are writing books to
start doing the audio version of the
books today's times really important
we're where do you work in you see Nia
what the Dean Joel okay guys hello Nico
recommend people watch the show yeah
definitely always I mean mashallah Shah
is amazing especially for people who
don't understand Islam and they should
actually listen to also the the
knowledge you actually teach people it
will actually make them understand Islam
in a better prospectively
and well as other people you know also I
know there's other brothers out there
who do try as well but you must love I
definitely make me in person Tom DeLonge
keep tuning into the deed show